all right let's close out with one last
feel good story I hope you'll enjoy as
much as I do this is what I'm liking
[Music]
collecting all
autographs pins but one St Louis man is
a curate of something crazy off beat
grocery lists which I'd never heard
exactly
um he says it gives him amazing insight
into humankind and we have him on the
line right now watching on kplr 11 at 3.
what's up Bill
hello
so this is so different so how did how
did this become a hobby uh well it
started back in the late 90s I was I was
shopping for a birthday party for my
then girlfriend now wife and when I left
the store I found a list on the ground
and it was just a normal boring list but
I found it interesting and I just
decided that over I just decided I would
pick them up whenever I saw them so over
the years I've collected nearly 4 000 a
lot of them donated by people who um who
found the website and just thought it
was an interesting project and sent them
in it was it was just really fun to see
people get so into the project
oh my God I mean all I'm hearing right
now is that people litter a lot like
they just leave their stuff like a lot
that's like crazy to me so can you tell
us more about like some of the lists
you've come across like which one that
you really stuck out to you sure uh the
ones that have bonus material on were
kind of fun like it's got the grocery
items but
um uh lots of them have Doodles or notes
and one of my favorites is it's it's
clearly a note from a wife to her
husband and he buys too much stuff at
the store the note is just if you buy
more rice I'll punch you and it's it was
meant in Good Humor I can tell but it's
it was just funny um a lot of them are
sweet though you know just uh regular
list of items and then whatever else you
want or get something you know fun at
the end of the list
um and you can tell a lot about uh
people from the list like when someone's
having a party or if they're sick and
not feeling well
um a lot of people are super organized
with their list and some just border on
on pure chaos when it comes down to it
they can be really entertaining but you
know I think that after actually looking
at the lists and spending a little time
with them and getting that peek into
other people's lives it actually makes
you more empathetic and just kind of you
know it's just so interesting to get
that Peak oh my God it's a really good
inside it's hilarious I've never thought
to even that that would even happen or
well that people would litter that much
thank you so much Bill this is so
interesting and cool I'm liking your
post right now
thank you
our season-long partner pilot pin makers
of G2 the go-to pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show want to honor truly
Unstoppable people and just cool
interesting people like you man so
they're going to be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars how's that sound
that sounds great that's awesome you
should you should make all those into
like a book and sell it it's hilarious
thank you so much for hanging with us
and thank you to all our guests this
hour Allison Williams
Miss Betty and kitty you have a great
dane if it's not time changes
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]